So Republicans have continued to make claims that
the election was stolen from Joe Biden. Very often
the claims contradict. They were too far to see
whether the votes were valid in Pennsylvania,
but they were close enough to see
that there was fraud happening
at the signature level in Pennsylvania. Well, hold
on. If you were too far, how did you see that?
Doesn't matter anyway. The point is they're
making all sorts of claims. The Washington
Post is now reporting that a Pennsylvania
postal worker whose claims have been cited
by top Republican officials as a whistleblower
exposing widespread irregularities has admitted
to U.S. Postal Service investigators that he
fabricated the allegations. This is according to
three officials briefed on the investigation and
a statement from a House congressional committee,
as reported by The Washington Post. This guy's
name is Richard Hopkins'. He claimed that a
postmaster in Pennsylvania told postal workers
start backdating ballots in order to get them to
count, even though they shouldn't. But according
to the House Oversight Committee, Hopkins', who is
32 years old, told investigators on Monday that he
made it up and he reportedly signed an affidavit
recanting his claims. The House Oversight
Committee tweeting, quote, Breaking news.
Erie, Pennsylvania, USPS whistleblower completely
recanted his allegations of a supervisor
tampering with mail in ballots after being. By
investigators, according to the inspector general,
IG, investigators informed committee staff
that they interviewed Hopkins, that Hopkins
recanted his allegations and did not explain why
he signed a false affidavit. Case closed. Right.
Maybe not so fast, because then in
a YouTube video, the same gentleman,
I'm assuming he's a gentleman, has Hopkins posted
a video saying, I did not recant. So he recanted
a recanting or denied the recanting. Remember
that a lot of this is tied into Project Veritas
and James O'Keefe, who have been hailing Hopkins'
as an American hero. They created a go go fund
me page for Hopkins, which raised more than
one hundred thousand dollars, although the
fundraising page was subsequently removed by Go
Fund Me. And at this point we don't really know.
Did this guy recant? Did he recant and recant his
recantation? Was the recantation falsely reported?
We don't really know. But what it seems
like is another Project Veritas scam
falling apart under the latest investigation, just
like others have no one. I don't know how anyone
still believes anything that Project Veritas
points out, points out or claims or puts out.
And number two, what is the truth
of this story at this point? Again,
the primary question remains, you have
to zoom out. And the primary question is,
do we have hard evidence of specific,
illegal or fraudulent votes at this time
that would suggest any state went the wrong way?
And the answer is no. There was a very interesting
Twitter thread put out by former FBI agent
Hasharon GAPA also, I believe, a CNN contributor.
And she pointed out that based on the counties
and the ballots being contested in Pennsylvania,
even if every single ballot in question was
fraudulently for Biden instead of Trump,
it is still not enough votes to overturn
the spread in Pennsylvania right now.
So we have to just remain calm, continue to
ask the questions. Is there actually evidence
of specific, fraudulent or illegal votes? And
has any court found the evidence compelling?
And that's a big piece of what we're going to
be talking about in the last segment today,
the idea of courts not being given a chance
to have a say. We'll get to that. I don't
want to get ahead of myself because I
want to talk about Mike Pompeo next.